States are going to be making decisions
very soon about whether we are
continuing the lockdown shutdowns
stay at home social distancing
guidelines or whether things are going
to start being loosen now some states
never really shut down cities within
those states may have taken measures but
there are states that never did anything
so I'm not really talking about them but
as an example here in Massachusetts
officially we are closed until May 4th
which is next Monday Charlie Baker the
Republican governor who's been doing a
pretty okay job handling things said
that sometime this week he will have
guidance about what is coming next and
there's speculation in a lot of states
about are we going until May 15 some
states already have are we going until
May 31st a couple of states already have
at least some degree what is the next
step and I think that as we think about
this next phase we need to be very real
about one element of this which I think
informs what needs to be done and it's
recognizing that there are many
Americans that are not going to tolerate
much more of what I would call a full
shutdown with as many business closures
as we have as much social distancing as
we have and to the degree that we've had
it in some states really for a month and
a half are closing in on two months at
this point in time but I want to be
really clear as I talk about this I'm
not saying open it up and let it rip the
way protesters want I'm not saying any
of that and I'm not saying that we
shouldn't be doing what we are doing
what I'm saying is I think that it would
be useful to find small ways of at least
making it feel like we're taking steps
in order to ensure more people actually
adhere to the most important elements of
these guidelines so the point of this
segment is I want to be truthful which
is tens of millions of Americans are
more or less at their limit or close to
it either psychologically or
economically and I believe that we are
getting closer to the end of governor's
being able to say everything stays
closed before people start ignoring more
and more of these guidelines so the
basis of this commentary is essentially
harm reduction some states are extended
through May 15
there are other states that are formally
shut down until the end of this month
and then may or may not open and I think
there's kind of an invisible wall an
imaginary wall sometime between May 15
and June 1 especially with the weather
getting nicer in many parts of the
country where if a governor comes out
and says we're shut down until June 15
we're shut down under July 1 I think it
may backfire and that there will be
people who start to completely ignore it
so here's my idea my recommendation
governors could consider instead of
saying we're just going to extend the
full full shutdown until June 1 or we're
going to extend the full shutdown until
June 15 or even July 1 which will cause
a lot of frustration for many people I
wouldn't advise governor's to instead
say I hear the frustration people are
psychologically and economically
exhausted from this so let me help you
and the point here is we want to prevent
reactions of another month screw it I'll
do whatever I want and instead create a
reaction of hey here's another month
during which here are three new things
that are being extended or opened up to
me I can do it I can keep wearing the
mask I can get you know all that stuff
so the idea is let's go really hard
until call it May 15th as an example if
you help me governor's could say and
stay inside as much as possible use
masks when you're out always stay six
feet apart from people at grocery stores
if you do all that stuff on May 15th
here are the three things I think we
will be able to do the three things
don't have to be huge but they should be
something because the problem of doing
March 15th to 31st and then being told
now it's all of April and then being
told it's now all of May is it doesn't
feel like anything is happening and
people are growing increasingly
frustrated even people who understand
that we have to be doing this and there
are reasons for why we are doing it so I
don't have the exact answers I don't
think gyms should be open Trump included
gyms on phase one of his reopening plan
I don't think that makes any sense I
think that's a bad idea
could you say with the wet
getting nicer places that have outdoor
seating you can essentially let people
have their takeout at the outdoor
seating no waiter service you've got to
reduce the density of the seating so you
know maybe tables are ten feet apart
would that be something with that that
would be thousands maybe tens of
thousands of restaurants where people
who have been just getting takeout and
taking it can bring the takeout to an
outdoor table sit there and have it no
waiter or waitress service would that
psychologically help and maybe provide a
little bit of a boost to restaurants
maybe I don't know could you say movie
theaters with masks mandatory could open
at ten percent capacity which means you
you know there's plenty of room for
people to be very far apart social
distancing in line to buy tickets and no
concession stands I don't know would
people even go would people want that
I'm not really sure I'm thinking out
loud here for the social distancing
component between friends and family
could they say outdoor gatherings in
your backyard or in the park or whatever
with masks among people not in high-risk
groups who have had no symptoms and
continue to have no symptoms as long as
you stay six feet apart would that feel
like a win
given how things have been for four six
seven close to eight weeks at this point
in time I don't know I'm thinking out
loud here but my point is if governor's
on April 30th say we're now extending
till May 31st
I believe the frustration will push a
lot of people to abandon all the
guidelines and that would be really bad
instead if we can feel like there's
progress imagine the governor says we
made it to April 30th thank you new
cases are down but they're still too
high to reopen I've determined we are
going not to phase one but to phase zero
point one and here are three things that
I am saying we can do carefully from May
1st to the 15th I'll check back in with
you in 15 days and see if we can do
anything else the feeling that things
are improving could actually get people
to people to more closely abide by masks
work from home all that stuff and then
we we may be better off over
all than creating frustration and
abandonment of the guidelines thinking
out loud let me know what you think
check this out the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months completely free skill shares the
online learning community with thousands
of classes on almost anything you can
imagine always taught by experts they
have classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
running a small business and much more I
recently took a very interesting class
called simple productivity how to
accomplish more with less and got a
bunch of great personal productivity
tips out of it we should allow ourselves
a little time every week to either get
creative keep your brain sharp learn
something new it's great for mental
health and almost all the classes are
under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video